In the middle of the Turkmenistan desert
is a 230 foot wide hole
and the hole
it’s on fire
In 1971 a group of Soviet petroleum geologists
set out across the desert of Turkmenistan
and they were on the hunt for petroleum
and when they found a place
that they thought would be full of oil
they decided to set up a drilling rig
unfortunately for them
they set this drilling rig up over what turned out to be
an enormous cavern of natural gas
and when they punched in through the top of the desert
the entire thing collapsed, taking the drilling rig with it
and even more problematic than that
now leaking from this gigantic hole
was methane gas
which is a potentially deadly and definitely super explosive gas
so the Soviet geologists did what was for them
the sensible thing
they lit the hole on fire
The scientists thought when they lit this crater of fire
that it would burn for a few weeks, maybe a few months
and then it would just extinguish itself
It has been burning for over 40 years
locals call this the gates of hell
or the door to hell
or more scientifically, the Darvaza Gas Crater
In 2009 the Turkmen president
declared that he wanted the gates of hell closed
Capped. That is was an embarrassment to the country
but that hasn’t happened
In fact, the Gates of Hell have become a kind of tourist site
even the minister of tourism
now sites it as one of their major attractions
and for a country that only sees
between ten and fifteen thousand tourists a year
it’s a big deal that people are excited
to go to the gates of hell.
It’s also said that the crater attracts
local spiders, drawn to the light and the heat
which come to the edge of the crater
and then throw themselves into it.
Presumably they are trying to reunite themselves
with their dark lord
the crater has been burning for 40 years
and there is no telling when it will stop
but with continued tourist interest
it’s likely that it may be burning for some time to come
Subscribe here
and watch more videos here